when you go to medical school you don't
get very much education and nutrition I
went back to school for biomedical
science I thought maybe I need to get a
PhD going to Immunology or microbiology
just try and figure out what's going on
I started researching trying to figure
out what this rash was and it took like
six months to identify this rash it was
called dermatitis herpetiformis and it's
a rash that people with celiac disease
can get that's the autoimmune disorder
caused by gluten so I started
researching celiac disease and I saw
that celiac disease can couple with
other autoimmune disorders and I was
like maybe I just have celiac disease so
I cut out gluten I probably improved by
10 so about four months later I thought
what are people allergic to eggs dairy
grains soy I cut out everything I could
think of that I thought maybe somebody
could be allergic to and I ended up with
basically meat heated fruit greens and a
certain root vegetables like parsnips
sweet potatoes and I went down to that
diet for a month my skin healed I lost
five pounds but I went down three pant
sizes so I had been bloated without even
knowing my arthritis started to feel
better so I started getting rid of my
medications